the corona virus pandemic has brought
out an altruistic streak in American
corporations and that includes those
helping children and education audible
has made hundreds of free streaming book
titles available for young people in
students and Logitech has provided free
webcams and headsets to teachers for
remote learning but even before the
pandemic one company has been helping
kids across the country get the school
supplies they need and it's attracted
some high-profile support it was a
full-on dance party with the DJ no less
when we paid a visit to public school
one in the Bronx New York this March are
you the most incredible students all
sparked by a man with a plan I don't
think anybody in this cost likes pencils
do that Australian entrepreneur Ito
Leffler is the co-founder of UB so can
you help us up a company that makes
vibrant school supplies and donates them
to you by UB gift you can go to Target
today you can buy a UB item mm-hmm and
every item you buy another item will be
given away we want to make school
supplies fun again but most importantly
our goal for UB is to provide free
school supplies to every child that
needs it here in the US UB focuses on
elementary schools where at least 70% of
students are eligible to receive free or
reduced cost lunch partnering with the
kids in need foundation to distribute
the goods someone gonna pick this up
we've been to the gym this morning each
classroom is gifted a 20 pound box of
supplies for 30 kids beautiful little
pencil case Oh
including pencils crayons and more UB
has donated more than 73 million school
supplies since being founded in 2014
most people look to the US is we're the
country of plenty why would you come and
seed here well I lived here for many
years I lived in a beautiful suburb in
California in Northern California and a
mile from where I lived was a school
that needed supplies much like this
wondered just didn't make sense to me
that a kid that lived in one postcode
versus a kid that lived in another zip
code that that that there were such
disparities celebrities have joined the
effort from baseball player yasiel Puig
and zendaya
to usher and Pharrell Williams Brito no
matter how far the stars are reach other
in America more than 12 million children
are from families in poverty a reality
all too familiar to Leffler I grew up
with a mom who was a schoolteacher my
mom the most she ever earned was twenty
five thousand dollars a year and yet she
would spend money out of her own pocket
every year on supplies for her classroom
for the kids that needed it something
many educators in the US can relate to
on average teachers make less than
$40,000 a year but spend nearly five
hundred dollars of their own money on
school supplies know that there's a
program out there organization that's
thinking about teachers having to go
into their pockets and spending money
I mean I'm super grateful what's your
favorite planet Tashia Maxwell has
taught here for five years and says what
the school does offer just isn't enough
my first week of my first year my
student came to me and was like you know
I need a book bag and I'm like okay well
you know just put your mom or tow dad
toe over that home that you need a book
bag no big deal
next a student comes back like my mom
said to tell you or ask you for the book
back and I'm like okay so now I realized
at that moment like this is my
responsibility like your space isn't my
responsibility
otherwise my student is literally going
to be carrying their books to and from
home we thank you hard of UT's giveaway
includes a thank you to teachers like
Maxwell
fifth-graders ICI any Herrera and
Angelica Nunez are two of her students
the man who did all of this his mother
was a teacher so how did that make you
feel when he came in and he just gives
the stuff away to you guys well I felt
happy because it was like a lot of
things inside do you need these things
yes you do
yeah why because before they gave us a
surprise at home I had no plans of that
I only have like about four grand but I
had a lot before me too and I colored
with those little crayons and then when
I saw the big packet of crayons
I felt different can you hand some out
as well these in person gives or
postponed for now but UB is still making
thousands of classroom packs available
at schools offering free meals with big
plans to help even more children believe
in themselves yeah I keep going back to
the idea of wanting to impact five
million kids a year we're up to about a
million kids a year now what do you need
to get their people support and you know
you know that every time you buy whether
it's a UB pencil case or a UB pen that's
gonna help a child right here in a
school such as this and for us if we can
impact those children and help them feel
more confident at school if we can help
them feel that they can turn up to
school and do their homework at home
because they've now have supplies that
they can take with them you know that
means a lot to us and obviously we shot
this before the pandemic started or the
lockdown we should say those teachers
the shoulder shouldering you know so
much of the expense of you know these
children and getting them what they need
in the classroom we see what they do
time in and time out so this is really a
great opportunity for them to sort of
like get beyond and help those kids out
such a great story Michelle and I'm
going out to buy stuff UV stuff
specifically because it's so amazing the
way that they are trying to help in such
an important way that you may not have
thought of before great great piece